Y a-t-il trop de violences policières en France ?
Oui, la France commune, c'était la partie républicaine.
Oui, l'écologie pétale de gauche. Oui.
Faut-il réduire l'immigration en Europe ?
Non. L'Europe est-elle en train de se déstabiliser ?
Non. Est-ce qu'il y a trop de riches en France ?
Euh, peut-être.
Mais moi, mon sujet, c'est pas dans les riches,
c'est les pauvres.
Ce qui est insupportable,
c'est la concentration des richesses.
Y a de plus en plus de millionnaires,
y a de plus en plus de milliardaires,
et ça, euh. C'est pas 1 signe de justice sociale.
Faut-il 1 candidat commun de la NUPES
en deux-mille-vingt-sept ?
Il faut 1 candidat
de l'union de la gauche et des
écologistes en deux-mille-vingt-sept ?
Faut-il mettre en
place de la discrimination positive
en faveur des minorités ?
Je pense que c'est. Euh. Il faut y réfléchir,
il faut y réfléchir.